members of the hundred and sixteen
Congress inherited the shutdown on the
day they were sworn in Nancy Cordes has
been following three new lawmakers
finding their way on Capitol Hill Nancy
good morning good morning imagine you
have just won your election and you come
here to Washington ready to make good on
your campaign promises and what you
encounter is a government that is
partially shut down and a city that is
paralyzed by this standoff that is the
situation our bipartisan group of
freshman Congress members find
themselves in as they try to find their
way on Capitol Hill this is my Korean
father Michigan Democrat Elissa slot Kim
was still unpacking boxes when she got a
surprise her first request for help they
do have responsibility to tell you
clearly and in writing what your status
is and it was a woman from Brighton
Michigan in my district saying I work
for the census I don't know if I'm
furloughed or not I don't know if I'll
be repaid or not can you help me figure
this out slot conditioner rack as a CIA
analyst it really is the first day I
mean there's no faking it here now she's
one of more than a hundred new House
members getting a crash course on the
powerful and limits of legislative our
new home as soon as Houston Republican
Dan Crenshaw began drawing a
congressman's paycheck that's a patch I
wore on my first deployment in Iraq he
announced he would forego that pay to
show solidarity with furloughed workers
the worst thing in the world is to have
that insecurity and to have that
uncertainty we followed slot Caen
Crenshaw and New Mexico Democrat Deb
Holland for the past month as they
prepared for their roles in divided
government this is kind of a cool
picture for Holland that meant packing
up half her home in Albuquerque
and saying goodbye to her 24 year old
daughter lives just down the street
I made her share her location with me on
my phone so I can like always see where
she is they are members of a younger
more diverse new class that isn't afraid
to make waves when someone comes we want
to make sure that they get a different
experience and they got with our
predecessor slot khun's first official
act slot can present with holding her
vote for the new speaker a fellow
Democrat Nancy Pelosi you have to hear
what people in your district are saying
and I got a very loud and clear signal
from people across the aisle that they
wanted new leadership even before he was
sworn in Crenshaw a former Navy SEAL who
lost an eye in Afghanistan wrote an
op-ed urging the White House to keep
troops in Syria did you struggle with
the idea that you would basically be
putting yourself at odds with the
president very early on on this issue I
have a background that makes me I think
an expert voice on this particular issue
one of the most memorable images from
their swearing-in was this one Holland
and Charisse David's of Kansas the first
two Native American women ever elected
to Congress said I didn't have a tissue
and you know decided to use this scarf
she said my scarf is your scarf so they
all know that to get anything done
they'll need to build relationships
service and veteran candidates have a
plan
to try to get together and stay together
as a block Crenshaw has a head start
thanks to this viral bid on SNL
[Music]
[Applause]
they've all arrived with big goals the
thing that I keep asking is who's
talking about health care it's talking
about prescription drugs what's the plan
when are we getting to this stuff but
there's one issue hanging over
everything and right now we need to be
talking about opening the government
right I mean everything is sort of
frozen yeah right don't say government
they're real people hurting right now in
our country and she says Native American
communities in particular in her state
and around the country are hard hit by
this shutdown because federal programs
having to do with medical care and law
enforcement have been halted on
reservations she's trying to figure out
ways to make up for the loss of some of
those services but John what all of
these lawmakers are finding is that
there's very little that Congress can do
other than funding these agencies and
getting the government reopened all
right Nancy thank you the pressure
continues to build